our top story tonight as almost too
disturbing for words early this morning
Empire star justice Millette was a
viciously attacked the victim of a
suspected hate crime
Jesse survived but what police say
happened him was truly horrific can you
head over check in a bear report
regarding a friend that was assaulted
man it must be well-known to the news
misplaced over the Pacific a source
tells ET the 35 year old actor was
brutally attacked in downtown Chicago
not far from where Jesse stays when
Empire shoots there we're told two men
yelled racial and homophobic slurs and
repeatedly hit him and our source says
at one point poured a substance on him
believed to be bleach our source also
claims that one of the men put a rope
around Jesse's neck the men fled the
scene and Jesse went to this nearby
hospital he was released early this
morning as for his condition today we're
told quote Jesse is mostly physically
okay with some scrapes and bruises but
he's more emotionally shook up right now
police are looking for witnesses and
Clues including we're told surveillance
video of the area Jesse flew in from New
York to Chicago just yesterday
instagramming his frustration over the
delayed flight
jessie is scheduled to perform Saturday
at a concert in West Hollywood although
it's unclear if he will be well enough
to take the stage Empire has really
begun to evolve Kevin was on set with
Jessie and Chicago in November the actor
came out as gay a few months after
Empire's premiere in 2015 and Jessie's
on-screen character Jamal who is also
gay recently got engaged
he's nothing frivolous about this
storyline you know it's a healthy
relationship between two men two black
men it's taken me a minute to come to
social media about this because Jessie
you are my son
Empire creator Lee Daniels posted an
emotional message this morning you
didn't deserve know anybody deserves to
have a news put around your neck to have
bleach thrown on you to be called dye or
whatever they said to you we are better
than America is better than that hold
your head up Jesse well et has learned
that Jesse and the rest of the Empire
cast will have armed security as
production of Empire continues
production is not shut down and is
ongoing
[Music]